Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速告诉大家一个现在正在进行的令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向经常性收入冲刺挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是一个有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Picture this, you're scrolling through social media and you're met with a cascade of triumphant posts from people who've bagged job offers in the highly coveted roles that you want.
这些原则都对你适用。丽莎本人还将亲自送出丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的一小时辅导。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。想象一下：你在浏览社交媒体时，迎面而来的是一连串那些在备受追捧的理想职位上拿到工作offer的人发出的欢庆帖子。
Meanwhile, you're left with that sinking feeling that you just didn't quite get what you wanted. But fear not, in today's episode we are diving headfirst into the turbulent waters of job rejections and disappointment in the field of psychology and mental health. Join me as we unpack the highs, the lows and the learning points involved in each one of those rejection emails. So grab your favourite mug, mine is a herbal tea, and join me as together we dive into this journey of resilience, determination and self-reflection. Hope you find it so useful.
与此同时，你却留下了那种感觉自己好像没有得到想要的东西的失落感。不过别担心，在今天的节目中，我们将一头扎进心理学和心理健康领域中充满波折的求职拒绝和失望的湍急水流中。和我一起，我们来剖析每一封拒绝邮件背后的高潮、低谷以及学习要点。所以，拿上你最喜欢的马克杯（我的是一杯草本茶），和我一起深入这段充满韧性、决心和自我反思的旅程吧。希望你觉得它非常有用。
Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I know that this time of year can feel really tricky. It can feel like everybody else is doing it, so why can't I? You might well notice the reference there from a Cranberries album. This time of year can feel really challenging. It can feel like everybody else is doing it, so why can't I? It can lead to self-reflection, self-criticism and also a dip in mood. Today I'm guiding you through eight consideration points that might help you to reposition yourself and help you bolster some
嗨，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。我知道每年的这个时候会让人感觉真的很棘手。这会让人觉得好像所有人都在这么做，为什么我不能？你可能注意到了这里对小红莓乐队（Cranberries）专辑的致敬。每年的这个时候会让人感觉极具挑战性。这会让人感觉好像所有人都在这么做，为什么我不能？这可能会导致自我反思、自我批判以及情绪低落。今天，我将引导大家了解八个思考要点，它们或许能帮你重新定位自己，并帮你重拾一些
enthusiasm to get through these next months. Firstly, number one, I think it's really important that we normalize this experience it does feel a lot like rejection and sometimes when you get the emails through it can feel like you've been kicked in the teeth or in the stomach or both that sense of disappointment that sense of rejection is really common in psychology and really common in all career fields, actually. And I really want to normalise how often this happens. When I got my first assistant psychologist post, for example, it was probably the 50th or 60th assistant psychologist job that I'd applied for,
热情来度过接下来的几个月。首先，第一点，我认为正视并正常化这种经历非常重要。这确实很像被拒绝，有时当你收到邮件时，会感觉像是被踢了牙齿或胃，或者两者兼有。这种失望感、这种拒绝感在心理学领域非常常见，实际上在所有职业领域也非常常见。我真的很想让大家明白这种情况发生的频率有多高。例如，当我得到第一份助理心理学家职位时，那大概是我申请的第50个或第60个助理心理学家工作，
maybe more. I didn't keep a note. It would have been helpful to do that wouldn't it and I know that it's even more competitive now and when I got on to clinical psychology doctoral training that was the third time that I had applied I know some of you may be listening to this and like yeah I'm happy to give it three goes but this is time number five and I know it's really hard but we also need to think about when we start applying as well because of course we know the minimum requirements are that you need to have for example for clinical psychology you need to have your degree and they recommend that it's at least a year or two after you've got your degree qualification and then you also need relevant experience and so if you do start applying before you have that relevant
也许更多。我没有做记录。如果做了记录会很有帮助，不是吗？而且我知道现在竞争更激烈了。当我进入临床心理学博士培训时，那是我第三次申请。我知道你们有些人听到这里可能会想：“好吧，我乐意尝试三次，但这是第五次了。”我也知道这真的很难。但我们还需要考虑我们是什么时候开始申请的，因为当然，我们知道最低要求是，例如对于临床心理学，你需要有学位，他们建议最好是在你获得学位资格后的一到两年，然后你还需要相关的经验。所以，如果你在拥有这些相关经验之前就开始申请，
experience then that's going to be a no not yet but it might be that actually you weren't quite ready for that but even if you are feeling like you are ready you might still feel like it's your time and you are ready but you are not getting shortlisted and others are and that is really hard. I know from my work in supporting aspiring psychologists through the podcast, through the compassionate Q&As and through my aspiring psychologist membership that actually you know the thing that most is predictive of success is perseverance and I know it's hard, I know it's hard to keep going. And I know it can feel like self-flagellation, self-punishment and kind of masochistic that we don't know whether there will ever be the prize
那么答案就会是“不，还不行”。但也有可能实际上你当时还没完全准备好。不过，即使你觉得自己已经准备好了，你可能仍然会觉得这是属于你的时刻、你已经准备好了，但你没有进入候选名单，而其他人进了，这真的很难。根据我通过播客、富有同情心的问答以及我的“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership）支持有抱负的心理学家的经验，我深知：最能预示成功特质的其实是坚持不懈。我知道这很难，我知道坚持下去很难。并且我知道，在我们不知道你追求的奖赏是否会到来时，
that you seek. But like I said, the one thing we know that makes it more likely is by continuing. It hurts. I know that. And it's okay to lean into that. It's okay to be sad. Talk to people who are on your team. Talk to people who, and when I say on your team, I don't necessarily mean in your job role. I mean people that get you, people that aren't going to minimize you, people aren't going to squash down. So when people are grieving and somebody might say, oh, well, they were quite old or they had a good innings or they've had, you know, they've had a good life. That's not that helpful. And those might not be the kinds of people that you want to seek support from at that time. We want you to be surrounded by people who get it, who are able to sit with your sadness and don't feel that need to fix it. So make sure you've got some people in your life
这可能会让人感觉像是在自我鞭笞、自我惩罚和某种苦行僧般的折磨。但就像我说的，我们知道能让成功概率更高的唯一一件事就是继续坚持。这很痛，我知道。去接纳这种痛苦是没问题的。感到难过是没问题的。去和站在你这边的人聊聊。去和那些——当我指“站在你这边的人”时，我并不一定指你在工作岗位上的同事，我是指那些懂你的人、不会贬低你的人、不会把你压下去的人。就像人们在哀悼时，有人可能会说：“哦，好吧，他年纪挺大了，或者他已经活够本了，或者你知道的，他度过了一个美好的人生。”那并没有什么帮助。而那些人可能不是你在那种时刻想要寻求支持的对象。我们希望你的身边都是那些能理解你、能够陪伴你的悲伤并且不觉得有必要去修复它的人。所以请确保你的生活中有一些人
who can do that. So that's our first point, normalising rejection. I've sort of strayed into the territory for point number two, which is resilience and persistence. Now this can feel dogged, it can feel like really hard work. What I noticed when I was putting together the Clinical Psychologist Collective and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, is that time and time again, people were talking about their resilience. They were talking about their persistence. They were talking about the reflection points that they got from setbacks, from being told no. Even my own experience of, you know, being told at undergraduate level that clinical psychology was really really hard to get into and you know you probably shouldn't bother go do something else
能够做到这一点。这就是我们的第一点：将拒绝正常化。我刚才有点偏离到第二点的领域了，也就是韧性和坚持。这可能会让人觉得很顽强，感觉像是一项非常艰辛的工作。当我把“临床心理学家集体”（Clinical Psychologist Collective）和“有抱负的心理学家集体”（Aspiring Psychologist Collective）汇编在一起时，我注意到，一次又一次地，人们都在谈论他们的韧性。他们在谈论他们的坚持。他们在谈论他们从挫折中、从被拒绝中获得的那些反思点。甚至我自己的经历——比如在本科阶段被告知临床心理学非常非常难进，
I was like right right I like a challenge I'm resilient I can do this which again is not necessarily the healthiest perspective but if that's what you're experiencing again that is normalizing that many of us do do that. Yeah, I'm trying to tell you to do it, but don't do it my way. But I know that you are still human and you're going to be having the same thoughts, feelings and thought processes that I did because you want it likely as much as I did. And as much as I do, you know, psychology and this field of psychology and clinical psychology for me is something I am saying yes to every day still even now even though I qualified in 2011 and I think that's really my top tip for this resilience and persistence is are you still saying yes to that if you are
“你知道的，你大概不应该费劲，去做点别的吧”。我当时的想法是：“好啊，好啊，我喜欢挑战，我有韧性，我能做到这一点。”这当然不一定是健康的观点，但如果你也有这样的经历，这同样是在说明，我们很多人确实都会这样做。（是的，我在试图教你这么做，但请不要学我的方式。）但我知道你仍然是个人，你将会拥有和我当时完全相同的思想、感受和思维过程，因为你和当时的、现在的我一样渴望它。对我来说，心理学和临床心理学这个领域是我即使在今天——尽管我在2011年就已经获得资格——也依然每天都在对它说“好”的事物。我认为这确实是我关于韧性和持久力的头号秘诀：你是否仍在对它说“好”？如果你仍在对它说“好”，
still saying yes to that that's okay you're choosing that it's like that old analogy of marriage you know you're choosing to keep saying yes to that, that's okay. You're choosing that. It's like that old analogy of marriage, you know, you're choosing to keep saying yes to that person that you've married every day and we need to be looking to make sure that that is still a relationship that you want to be in with your pursuit of psychology. If it is, then you can keep going, but do make sure that you've got those people around you who help make the journey that little bit more compassionate. Point number three is self-reflection. Take a moment to look back at your job application and if that is a doctoral process then look back at the form that you applied. Look at it with fresh eyes if you can. So try to be extracted from the process where you're
那没关系，这是你的选择。这就好比婚姻的那个老比喻，你知道的，你每天都在选择对你结婚的那个人继续说“好”。我们需要确保这仍然是你想要与你的心理学追求维持的关系。如果是的话，你可以继续前进，但一定要确保你的周围有那些能让这段旅程多一点同理心的人。第三点是自我反思。花点时间回顾一下你的求职申请，如果那是博士申请流程，那就回顾你申请时填写的表格。如果可以的话，用全新的眼光去看待它。试着将自己从那个正在思考的自己的过程中抽离出来。当然，当你回过头来反思这一点时，距离你申请可能已经过去几个月了。
thinking about that as yourself. Of course, by the time that you are coming back to reflect on this, it is likely to have been some months since you applied. So what we would expect is that you would have had new insights, new thoughts, new reflections, new learning objectives, new ways of thinking about things. You know, subsequent supervision sessions or learning experiences with clients that have led you to think about things differently. As you look at your form, look at what you would do differently. Is everything you've written powerful, punchy? Have you written too much about something? Have you not left enough room to talk about other things? Sometimes we can be a little bit more succinct, which means we can
所以我们期望的是，你将会有新的见解、新的想法、新的反思、新的学习目标、新的思考事物的方式。你知道的，随后的督导会议或与客户的学习经历，会引导你以不同的方式看待事物。当你审视自己的表格时，看看你会做哪些不同的处理。你写的所有东西都有力量、有冲击力吗？你是不是在某个方面写了太多？你是不是没有留出足够的空间来谈论其他事情？有时我们可以更简练一些，这意味着我们可以在申请表中
get more bang for our buck in our application forms. As part of this reflection section, it might be that you can invite feedback from other people as well. Perhaps somebody else that has either been successful or hasn't been successful, maybe even your supervisor or manager or other people in your team who have a valid and useful viewpoint it can be useful as well to get people who are non experts to look at your form as well to make sure that it makes sense from a common sense perspective but also that it's interesting that we can forget that it's supposed to be an interesting thing to read. It isn't just all supposed to be, I don't know, formulaic and doom and gloom and boring. It's supposed to be interesting. It's supposed to be engaging. And you might well find
获得更高的投入产出比。作为这一反思部分的一部分，你或许也可以邀请其他人提供反馈。也许是另一个曾经成功或没有成功的人，甚至可能是你的督导、经理或团队中的其他人，他们拥有有效且有用的观点。让非专家来看一下你的表格也很有用，以确保它从常识的角度来看是讲得通的，而且它很有趣——我们有时会忘记它本该是一件有趣的事情。它不应该全部都是，我不知道，刻板、厄运、阴暗而且无聊的。它本该是有趣的。它本该是引人入胜的。你可能还会发现，
it helpful to listen back to the episode I did with Nikita, where she talks about some of the lively ways that she perked up her form and that episode was called how to get on to clinical training in record time or something like that we mustn't forget of course that we do learn things from experiences that don't go our way feels like a little bit of an excrement sandwich that you feel like you're having to learn stuff from the stuff that goes well to make it more palatable. I really do think we can learn from the things that we don't get. You know, it makes me think of, you know, when you're looking for something and you're like, you might say, and it was in the last place I looked. Well, of course it was in the last place you looked,
回听我和尼基塔（Nikita）的那期播客会很有帮助，她在节目中谈到了她让自己的表格充满生机的一些妙招，那期节目叫做《如何以创纪录的速度进入临床培训》或者类似的名字。当然，我们绝不能忘记，我们确实能从那些不如意的经历中学到东西。这感觉有点像一小块“排泄物三明治”，你觉得你不得不从那些顺利的事情中学习东西来让它更容易下咽。但我真的认为我们可以从那些我们没有得到的事务中学习。你知道的，这让我想起，当你寻找某样东西时，你可能会说：“它在最后我找的地方。”嗯，它当然在最后你找的地方，
because then you stopped looking because you'd found it. it's what do we find what do we discover along the way might well help us put strategies in place so that we don't lose our keys for example so that we can make our next experience of applying more frictionless because we're not wasting time we're being more purposeful we're being more purposeful, we're being more focused, we are having less chance for setbacks. It's that process of errorless learning that you might well have learnt about in your undergraduate or your A-level studies. That's what we're looking to do here, we're looking to make this job application, job interview experience as friction-free as possible so that the next time we've got a better chance of success. Point number four is exploring alternatives. Now I know I said that resilience and determination was important but you also matter and it might be that you decide to down
因为那时你找到了，所以你就停止寻找了。我们在沿途发现的、探索到的东西，可能确实能帮助我们制定策略，这样我们就不会丢失钥匙，从而能让我们的下一次申请经历更加顺畅，因为我们没有浪费时间，我们更有目标性，我们更有重点，我们遭遇挫折的机会更少。这就是你在本科或高级水准（A-level）学习中可能学到过的“无错误学习”（errorless learning）的过程。这正是我们在这里所追求的，我们希望让这份求职申请、面试经历尽可能地顺畅，这样下次我们就有更好的成功机会。第四点是探索替代方案。现在，我知道我曾说过韧性和决心很重要，但你也同样重要，你可能决定暂时放下
tools for a bit, that you decide to go and do something different. You decide to go travelling or to explore something different and then come back to psychology at a later stage. Or it might just be that you decide, actually, clearly this job role that I've got at the moment isn't helping me develop or grow in the way that I need to. Or maybe I have developed and grown as much as I can from this job role and it's time to think about broadening to a different clinical area or to a more clinically relevant area or experience. Maybe you can move to a job where you're supervised by a qualified psychologist, maybe you can move to a job where it's a training role and whilst that might mean that you are tied in for a little bit for a few years because perhaps you've accessed
手中的工具，去尝试做点别的。你决定去旅行或探索不同的事物，然后在稍后阶段再回到心理学。或者也可能只是你决定，事实上，显然我目前的工作并没有以我需要的方式帮助我发展或成长。或者也许我已经从这份工作中获得了尽可能多的发展和成长，现在是时候考虑拓展到一个不同的临床领域，或者一个更具临床相关性的领域或经验了。也许你可以换到一份由合格心理学家督导的工作，也许你可以换到一份培训性质的工作。虽然这可能意味着你会被绑定几年，因为你可能获得了
higher education England funding, it might still be worth it in the long run because of what you learn and how you're able to use those skills to make sure that ultimately you are successful. Maybe you could look at maybe making your role part-time so that you've got capacity to be able to engage in a different part-time, hopefully paid role. Money is important, it does make your life that bit easier to manage. But maybe there's potential for you to drop down to be able to give you more capacity for learning about different clinical areas, different clinical populations within your same 37 and a half hours a week. Now I will level with you, having done split posts, it does feel like you are doing more than a whole time equivalent role. So you need to go into that with your eyes open as well. But you do learn so much in the early months of a new role. And I remember when I was in training
英格兰高等教育资金（Higher Education England funding）的支持，但从长远来看，它仍然是值得的，因为你学到的知识以及你如何运用这些技能来确保最终取得成功。也许你可以考虑把你的工作调整为兼职，这样你就有能力去从事另一份兼职的、最好是有薪的工作。金钱很重要，它确实能让你的生活更容易管理。但也许你有潜力减少工作时间，以便腾出更多精力来在每周同样37.5小时内了解不同的临床领域、不同的临床人群。现在我跟你交个底，做分职工作（split posts）的感觉确实像是做着一份超过全职工作量的工作。所以你也需要带着清醒的认识去做这件事。但在新工作的前几个月里，你确实学到了很多东西。我记得我在培训时，
that you have such a rapid expansion of knowledge, skills and expertise in those early days, weeks and months. You know, you still, you feel like maybe you plateau by the time you're reaching the end of the placement. You feel like you're probably getting into your stride by the end of the six months. Really, probably as much as you're going to learn about that clinical population has come in those first few months, I would say. And in those, you know, formative conversations that you will have with your clinical supervisor, with your manager, with the people around you. So could you broaden your experience to include another job role, hopefully, like I said, a paid job role. If you are considering honoree work, please do check out
在那些早期日子、几周和几个月里，你的知识、技能和专长会经历如此迅猛的扩张。你知道的，当你走到实习快结束时，你可能会觉得自己已经进入了平台期。你可能会觉得在六个月结束时你大概已经进入状态了。真的，关于那个临床群体的知识，你可能学到的最大部分都来自于最初的几个月，我会这么说。在那些与你的临床督导、经理以及你周围的人进行的、具有决定意义的对话中。那么，你是否可以拓宽你的经验，包含另一份工作——最好就像我说的，是一份有薪工作。如果你在考虑义工性质的工作（honorary work），请务必查看
my recent video on why honoree roles are problematic. When we are considering broadening our repertoire, our job search, then the Inspiring Psychologist Collective book can be really really useful in that because in that people discuss the job roles they've applied for, people discuss the job roles they've had and you know if we don't know what the job titles are, it can be really difficult to search for them. So you might well find that to be a useful read. Now, let's have a quick break and I will be back along very soon. Reflective accounts of mental health professionals on their way to getting qualified. So many tips and lessons to learn from.
我最近关于为什么义工角色存在问题的视频。当我们考虑拓宽我们的技能组合、我们的求职范围时，《有抱负的心理学家集体》这本书会非常非常有用，因为在这本书中，人们讨论了他们申请过的职位，讨论了他们担任过的职位。你知道的，如果我们不知道职位名称是什么，寻找它们就会非常困难。所以你可能会发现这是一本很有阅读价值的书。现在，让我们休息一下，我很快就会回来。心理健康专业人士在通往获得资格的道路上的反思记录。有这么多的技巧和经验教训可以学习。
So many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. Welcome back along. Do these jingles get stuck in your head in the way that they do mine? How are you finding this podcast? I would love your feedback. I would love to have your voice on the podcast telling me about your experiences with the podcast or with the membership or even with the free compassionate Q&As or with the Clinical Psychologist Collective book or the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book, please do get in contact with me. You can go to my website www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast and you can
有这么多的事情你可以尝试。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。欢迎回来。这些音乐铃声会不会像对我一样也一直卡在你的脑海里？你觉得这个podcast怎么样？我非常需要你的反馈。我非常希望在播客中听到你的声音，告诉我你对这个播客、会员计划、甚至是免费的富有同情心的问答，或是《临床心理学家集体》这本书或《有抱负的心理学家集体》这本书的体验，请务必联系我。你可以访问我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk 斜杠 podcast，你可以在那里
learn there how to leave me an audio testimonial or just drop me a voice note on Instagram or LinkedIn and we can go from there. And please also do take a moment to rate the podcast if you're listening on Spotify and if you're listening on Apple Podcasts please do rate and review the podcast as it helps us to reach a wider audience and one of the most beneficial things you can do for me for free which takes you less than a nanosecond, is to click subscribe or follow on the platform that you are watching or listening to this on. So in the first half of this episode, we were looking at my top four ways for navigating your way through that sense of, oh no, everyone else is getting the job offers that I want. And I'm going to be bringing you four more reflection
了解如何给我留下一条音频评价，或者只是在 Instagram 或 LinkedIn 上给我发一条语音便签，我们就可以从那里开始。如果你在 Spotify 上收听，也请花一点时间给这个播客评分；如果你在 Apple Podcasts 上收听，请务必给这个播客评分并撰写评论，因为这有助于我们接触到更广泛的受众。你能为我做的、完全免费且对你来说不到一纳秒时间的最有益的事情之一，就是在你观看或收听的平台上点击订阅或关注。所以在本集的前半部分，我们探讨了我的四大顶级方法，帮助你度过那种“哦，不，其他人都在拿到我想要的职位”的感觉。接下来我将带给你关于这个热门、痛苦、让人心痛的话题的另外四个反思
and thought points around this hot, painful, ouchy topic, number five. And it is looking after your wellbeing. I know this is really hard. I know that it feels like your whole life is on hold. And I know that this is something that you really really want but the importance of talking about that with people who get it but also people who just love and adore you is so important. Do other things as well as psychology, have other hobbies,
与思考点：第五点。那就是照顾好你的身心健康。我知道这真的很难。我知道这感觉像是你的整个人生都按下了暂停键，而且我知道这是你非常非常渴望的事情。但与那些懂你的人，以及那些真正爱你、崇拜你的人谈论这一点是多么重要啊。除了心理学之外，还要做其他事情，培养其他的爱好，
know that it's okay to pursue those so I only really got into exercise probably about four years ago but I really wish I got it sooner because actually I really enjoy running and weight training and it really helps me manage everything that I've got going on you might not be into running You might not be into running, you might not be into weight training, but hopefully there's some other form of exercise, maybe something that helps you do mindfulness as well, like yoga or Pilates, something that gets your heart racing, but can give you space to do something different, something where you are immersed in that moment. And when you're lifting a really heavy weight, you can't really think about anything else. So that is the
要知道去追求这些是完全可以的。所以我大概在四年前才真正开始接触运动，但我真的很希望我能早点开始，因为事实上我真的很喜欢跑步和力量训练，它确实帮我应付了我生活中的所有事情。你可能不喜欢跑步，
beauty of it giving you a transformation, of giving you a break. And actually, sometimes when I'm in a really bad mood, and I go and see my personal trainer, I just feel different afterwards, because I've used my body and I've used my mind in a very different way and it just alters my whole being my whole you know the way I kind of spring out of there after that is it is transformative and so please do consider whether exercise you know and this is ability inclusive as well you know whatever your level of ability is there is something you can do that stretches your body that stretches your mind that gives you a best chance of using it as a well-being activity please do know that i get it
你可能不喜欢跑步，你可能不喜欢力量训练，但希望你还有其他形式的运动，也许是某种也能帮你进行正念的运动，比如瑜伽或普拉提，某种能让你的心跳加速、但能给你空间去做不同事情的运动——那种让你完全沉浸在那一刻的事情。当你举起一个非常重的重量时，你其实无法思考其他任何事情。所以这就是它的美妙之处：它给你带来转变，给你一个喘息的机会。事实上，有时当我心情真的很糟糕时，我去见我的私人教练，之后我就会感觉完全不同了，因为我以一种非常不同的方式使用了我的身体和思维，它改变了我的整个存在、我的整个……你知道的，我之后从那儿像春天般跃出来的样子是具有变革性的。所以请务必考虑运动是否（而且这也是具有包容性的，不管你的能力水平如何，总有某种东西是你可以做的，能够舒展你的身体、舒展你的思维，给你最好的机会把它当作一项身心健康活动）——请务必知道我是懂你的，
you know this is really hard one of the really great things about the Aspiring Psychologist membership is that other people are around who get it just like you do and who aren't going to try and cheer you up, who just are able to sit with you. So please do consider whether the Aspiring Psychologist membership might also be a really great way of looking after your well-being but also of helping you maximize your chances of success in the future. Tip number six is networking and professional development. Now of course networking is something that I do really well on LinkedIn so do come over and connect with me on there. Get involved in my comments, get involved in sharing the posts and liking them, having
你知道的，这真的很难。“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”真的很棒的一点在于，周围有其他人能懂你，就像你懂他们一样，他们不会试图去哄你开心，而是能够静静地陪伴你。所以请务必考虑“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”是否也是照顾你身心健康的绝佳途径，同时也能帮助你最大化未来成功的机会。第6点是社交网络与职业发展。当然，社交网络是我在领英（LinkedIn）上做得很好的事情，所以快来那里与我建立联系吧。参与我的评论区，参与分享帖子并点赞，
conversations with people in the comments as well. That's where the gold happens. You know, that's where many of the guests for the podcast come from, is from interesting conversations on LinkedIn. And when we follow people who inspire us, it can lead us to have different ways of thinking about tackling our problems. I love LinkedIn. I know I talk about LinkedIn all the time, but I really do see it as a brilliant professional networking site. But, you know, regardless of what stage of your career you are at, get on LinkedIn, because I honestly believe it will help you get there quicker. But LinkedIn isn't the only way to network and to kind of think about broadening your business relationships.
也和评论区的人们进行对话。黄金机会就诞生在那里。你知道的，播客的许多嘉宾都是从领英上有趣的对话中产生的。当我们关注那些激励我们的人时，它会引导我们用不同的方式去思考如何解决我们的问题。我喜欢领英。我知道我一直在谈论领英，但我真的认为它是一个极佳的专业社交网站。但是，无论你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，都请加入领英，因为我真心相信它会帮助你更快地到达目的地。但领英并不是唯一建立社交网络和拓宽商业关系的方式。
You can go to conferences, you can go to training events. They might well be something that's funded for you by your employer, but you may still have to search for that yourself. Sometimes these opportunities don't just end up in your email inbox. You know, you could consider joining the British Psychological Society if that's something you felt like you wanted to do. And they will send you any relevant networking or training events. They are not free. I am part of the Association for Clinical Psychology as well, the ACP and their events once I am a member they are free but I don't actually think you can register as an undergrad let me just check that out for you.
你可以去参加会议，你可以去参加培训活动。这些可能正是你的雇主为你资助的，但你可能仍然需要自己去寻找它们。有时这些机会不会无缘无故地掉进你的电子邮箱里。你知道的，如果你觉得这是你想做的事，你可以考虑加入英国心理学会（British Psychological Society）。他们会向你发送任何相关的社交或培训活动。它们不是免费的。我也是临床心理学协会（Association for Clinical Psychology, 简称ACP）的成员，一旦我成为了会员，他们的活动就是免费的，但其实我觉得你作为本科生是无法注册的，让我为你查一下。
So I've just had a little look and the ACP is only available to trainee psychologists or qualified clinical psychologists or those that want to be affiliated but aren't eligible for full registration. But you might well find it useful to go to local research meetings or kind of trust events that are happening, local aspiring psychologist meetings in your trust to maybe set your own up. Invite interesting people to come and talk to you and that's something that's something I've done for assistant psychologist groups as well. You know you can you can create what you want to see or you can come on board to what's already available. Having conversations is a key part of being a psychologist. And so don't be afraid to do it.
所以我刚刚查了一下，ACP只对见习心理学家、合格的临床心理学家开放，或者对那些想要加入但没有资格进行完整注册的人开放。但你可能会发现去参加当地的研究会议、或者在你所属的医疗信托基金（trust）中发生的当地活动、或者在你的信托基金中建立自己的“有抱负的心理学家”会议会很有用。邀请有趣的人来和你交流，这也是我为助理心理学家小组做过的事情。你知道的，你可以创造你想看到的，或者你可以加入已经存在的事物。进行对话是成为一名心理学家的关键部分。所以不要害怕去做这件事。
You know, do connect with people on LinkedIn. Do follow people. You know, do the same on Instagram. Just, you know, engage, be interested and learn. Point number seven is that we are setting realistic expectations. We are pacing ourselves. We are knowing that actually maybe applying for a doctorate when you're one month out of finishing your degree or perhaps when you are in the middle of a two or three year master's study program might not be
你知道的，在领英上与人建立联系。去关注他人。你知道的，在 Instagram 上也这样做。只需，你知道的，去互动、去保持兴趣并去学习。第七点是我们要设定现实的期望。我们要掌控好自己的节奏。我们要知道，事实上，也许在大学毕业仅一个月后，或者也许在你处于一个为期两三年的硕士学习项目的中途时去申请博士学位，可能并不是
that realistic it's not always impossible it isn't always impossible but pacing yourself and making sure that really this is your time and you're ready for this next step can be really really important and you know I have had very recent experiences with people who maybe applied to courses all over the UK and maybe were offered one furthest from their home and maybe they wish that they declined it because actually the realities of living so far away from your support systems and everything you know isn't always as rosy as you might have expected. So really be realistic when you are thinking about which courses, which job offers you want to apply to. And you might well have been in my world for a little while and you might well recall that I've already spoken
那么现实。这并不总是完全不可能的，它并不是总是办不到的，但掌握好节奏并确保这真的是你的时刻、你已经为下一步做好了准备，这真的非常非常重要。你知道的，我最近确实有过这样的经历：有些人可能向全英国的课程提交了申请，也许被录取的离他们家最远，也许他们后悔拒绝了它，因为实际上离你的支持系统和所有你熟悉的一切那么远的生活现实，并不总是像你预期得那么美好。所以在考虑你想申请哪些课程、哪些工作offer时，一定要切合实际。你可能已经在我的世界里待了一段时间了，你可能还记得我已经谈过
about my experiences kind of burning out, crying on the stairs because I was applying to job offers in Birmingham, in the Lake District, in Nottingham, and I was living in between Northampton and Milton Keynes. And it's just a lot, you know, you can't do it all. And so just being realistic with yourself, giving yourself, you know, the kindest journey that you can and the most compassionate is so important. There is no guarantee in this field but what we know is that by keeping our hand in and you know trying to learn, trying to grow, trying to develop, trying to take on feedback from people that we trust and value and respect can improve your chances you know practice reflection practice vulnerability in your supervision sessions and that will hopefully pay rich dividends last but not least we have point number eight and it's celebrating those small wins. On my computer I have a folder that I call the smile file and it's
我自己的经历：精疲力竭，在楼梯上哭泣，因为我当时在伯明翰、湖区、诺丁汉申请工作offer，而我住在北安普顿和米尔顿凯恩斯之间。这真的是太多的负担了，你知道的，你无法做到所有事情。所以，对自己保持现实，给自己一段你所能做到的、最温和且充满同情心的旅程是如此重要。在这个领域没有绝对的保证，但我们知道的是，通过保持参与，并且你知道的，去学习、去成长、去发展、去接受我们信任、重视和尊敬的人的反馈，可以提高你的机会。你知道的，在你的督导会议中练习反思、练习脆弱性，希望这会带来丰厚的回报。最后但同样重要的是，我们有第八点：庆祝那些小小的胜利。在我的电脑里，我有一个文件夹，我称之为“微笑文件”（smile file），
whenever I get something nice happen to me or said about me or things I think about myself I add it in there so that when I'm feeling like I've got a little bit of a low ebb, I can go along to that and reflect on things that have been enjoyable, maybe things I've got to look forward to as well. My sister-in-law is a big advocate of using her fridge to display lists of things that she's got coming up that feel really exciting. And that might well be something you can use as a mood board, use an aspiration. If your aspiration is to be a qualified clinical psychologist or a trainee board, use an aspiration. If your aspiration is to be a qualified clinical psychologist or a trainee clinical psychologist or educational psychologist or forensic psychologist, for example, then you can set that. You can put that on your fridge as a, you know, not necessarily
每当我遇到美好的事情、听到关于我的美好评价、或者有关于我自己的积极想法时，我都把它加进去。这样，当我觉得自己处于情绪低谷时，我就可以去那个文件夹，反思那些令人愉快的事情，也许还有那些我所期待的事情。我嫂子非常主张在冰箱上贴满她即将经历的、感觉非常令人兴奋的事情的清单。而这可能正是你可以用作情绪板、用作抱负的东西。如果你的抱负是成为一名合格的临床心理学家、或者见习临床心理学家、或者教育心理学家、或者法医心理学家，例如，那么你就可以设定这个目标。你可以把它贴在冰箱上，作为一种——不一定是
as a manifestation technique, but to remind yourself day after day where you're going, where you're heading to and why. So yes, celebrating and kind of goal setting is point eight. I hope you have found this useful. I would love any thoughts that you have got. Come along and connect with me on social media. I am Dr Marianne Trent everywhere. If you're watching this on YouTube, let me know in the comments what you think to this episode please do like share tell your friends do subscribe do all those good things and please do check out my back catalogue of free q and a session the compassionate q and a i'm on your team i would like to be able to support you more, but I need to know how to do that. So if there's something that you would like, do get in contact. Do let me know. Please, if you
作为一种显化技巧（manifestation technique），而是为了日复一日地提醒你自己，你要去哪里、你要朝哪个方向前进、以及原因何在。所以是的，庆祝和设定目标就是第八点。希望你觉得这很有用。我很乐意听到你的任何想法。来社交媒体上与我联系吧。我到处都是 Dr Marianne Trent。如果你在 YouTube 上观看此节目，请在评论区告诉我你对这一集的看法。请务必点赞、分享、告诉你的朋友、订阅、做所有这些美好的事情，也请查看我的免费 Q&A 课程的资料库——“富有同情心的 Q&A”。我和你站在同一战线。我希望能够为你提供更多支持，但我需要知道如何做到这一点。所以如果你有什么需求，请联系我，让我知道。请，如果你
do find these episodes helpful, please do leave me an audio testimonial. If you've read the books, please do leave me a Goodreads or Amazon review. It is so welcomed. Be kind to yourself this is not an easy process but I know that it is worthwhile at least for me because every day I am still choosing to say yes to self-coaching thank you so much for being part of my world be kind to yourself and I'll see you for the next episode, which will be landing at 10 a.m. on Saturdays on YouTube and 6 a.m. on Mondays for the MP3. Take care. Bye. with this podcast that you'll find to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr Marianne Trent my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical
确实觉得这些单集很有帮助，请务必给我留下一条音频评价。如果你读过这些书，请务必在 Goodreads 或 Amazon 上给我留下一条书评。这真是感激不尽。善待自己，这不是一个简单的过程，但我知道这是值得的，至少对我来说是这样的，因为每一天我都在选择对自我指导说“好”。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。善待自己，我们下期节目见，下期节目将于周六上午10点在 YouTube 上线，周一上午6点在 MP3 上线。保重，再见。通过这个播客，你会发现自己正在通往获得资格的道路上。这就是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我的名字叫亚娜（Jana），我是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。
psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现其中关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。它让我惊叹于通往那里的途径竟然有那么多，而且并没有成为其中一员的完美方式，这让我充满信心：不，我没有做错，并且减轻了我自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会把书放下来。这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。